[Music]
foreign
thank you
good morning and welcome to Sophie Ridge
on Sunday hello I'm Trevor Phillips
sitting in for Sophie who's away
well he might come up to the top of the
hill and he marks them down again but
this morning yevgeny precaution is off
to Belarus probably with pockets stuffed
with Moscow gold having humiliated the
Russian president
yesterday Vladimir Putin called his
former Ally a criminal traitor and
promised to crush the Rebellion this
morning the mercenary leader received a
pardon even before there's been a trial
maybe Mr Putin should have paid more
attention to Hillary Clinton who once
rather wisely said you can't keep snakes
in your backyard and expect them only to
bite your neighbors
back home who's up and who's down well
there's no sign of the labor party's
political Advance slowing they think
they're up the conservative government
seems helpless in the face of stubborn
inflation so most people reckon they're
down
north of the Border there's chaos in the
ranks of the Scottish national party
over their finances but the Nations
still split over Independence so maybe
the SMP is neither up nor down well in
the next 60 minutes we'll try to work
out who's right and who's wrong
[Music]
I'll speak to the first minister of
Scotland and leader of the embattled SNP
Hamza Yusuf
for the government here in Westminster
I'll be joined by the chief secretary to
the treasury John Glenn
and for labor the shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa nandi
after that extraordinary 24 hours in
Russia we'll try to work out what it
means for the conflict in Ukraine with
the former head of the British army
General Lord dannett
and we'll have extra Expo analysis from
former British Intelligence Officers
Christopher Steele and Philip Ingram
plus we'll have a live update from
Moscow with our very own Diana magnet
[Music]
well plenty of important domestic
matters to talk about today not least of
course the economy and inflation which
we'll get to shortly but let's start
this morning with some immediate live
reaction to the events in Russia from
the government I'm joined now by the
chief secretary to the treasury that's
John Glenn good morning Mr Glenn good
morning now um the government's
emergency response committee Cobra met
yesterday
um
what is the government's understanding
of the situation in Russia this morning
we were right Cobra was convened chaired
by the foreign secretary this is
fundamentally an internal matter for
Russia obviously observing it it is
obviously a very unstable situation in
Russia but it is fundamentally uh an
internal matter and we've obviously
urged alongside our allies which
conversations have been had over the
last 24 hours that obviously civilian
interests are considered and they seem
to have done that but this isn't a
matter that we would be intervening in
but obviously we observe and monitor the
situation on an ongoing basis very
carefully oh well look I know I know
that the Diplomatic language is it's an
internal matter not for us to comment on
and all the rest of it but doesn't this
alter the equation in Ukraine where we
have invested billions and where we have
an interest well we as a government have
been committed from the start on
supporting Ukraine in their battle
against what Putin has done and we will
continue to remain focused on that we
continue to train troops support with
military support and we're United with
our allies in leading in that effort
that will continue that is a separate
matter to what's happening in Russia
over the last couple of days uh did I
hear you say we've sent troops to the
Ukraine we've been training troops I
visited them in Salisbury Plain just
this week okay so uh this involves no
interruption or indeed no escalation of
our effort because there are some people
who would now say that actually
um this might mean an escalation by the
Russians or in their assault on Ukraine
the Wagner merceries are now we
understand being integrated with Russian
troops so might this be the moment for a
bit more support for Mr zielinski and
his team well we will work very closely
with Ukraine as the situations evolved
and as it has evolved over uh recent
months and that is our primary focus
supporting Ukraine deal with Putin in
whatever form that attack takes and it
has evolved over recent months so
nothing has changed with respect to the
British government's position in
supporting Ukraine I obviously recognize
these are concerning events uh of what's
happened in Russia but as I said we will
remain very close to our allies Cobra
has evaluated alongside our allies what
has been happening and urged concerns of
civilians to be taken into account but
this isn't something that we would
intervene in it's an internal matter for
Russia all right well let's um talk
about the things that are internal to us
under your the economy your control the
economy let's let's start with that um
inflation in this country is running
much higher than in uh comparable
countries we compare for example with
the Eurozone and the Americans the
Americans down there at four percent
um but it's not actually just a level
but the fact that
the Americans uh inflation is down a bit
the Eurozone is down a bit ours is stuck
at 8.7 now we know the bank of England
has got its one Club interest rates
they've uh put on 50 50 basis points
this week let's talk about what the
government can do what give me one thing
that you in the treasury are doing to
tackle this inflation well as Chief
secretary to the treasury my
responsibility uh fundamentally and
primarily is to control public spending
and that is an incredibly challenging
job at this time because obviously we
had a three-year comprehensive spending
review uh two years back and obviously
these inflationary pressures bear down
across all our public expenditure on
Capital expending and on day-to-day
expenditure but keeping a grip on public
spending making tough decisions on
reprioritization putting an efficiency
Savings review Into the preparation for
the last fiscal event the last budget
and you will know obviously that the
chancellor asked me to lead a
productivity review which I'm now
undergoing and that will happen over the
next few months looking at how we can
control public spending at a very
difficult time as we still deal with
many legacies from covid all very
sensible but explain to me how any of
that has any bearing on that 8.7 percent
figure in the next few months which is
when it's hurting well I can understand
and I really do understand because I
obviously I have constituents who email
me or concerned about the implications
of higher interest rates for their
household budgets but there isn't a
single quick lever that I can give you a
sound bite I'm just asking you for one
well one contribution well I think there
are three elements to the government's
response the independent monetary policy
interest rates which you've described
controlling public expenditure and then
helping with those additional costs so
we've helped with those energy bills and
we extended that in the spring budget
but I I would just yeah panels are
coming down anyway can I the big thing
here is mortgages isn't it can I can I
just point out that I think by putting
one screenshot on on your screen you
failed to show the fact that the
interest rate pressures across the
across Europe and across many of our
allies Australia Canada U.S interest
rates have gone up the fastest rate
since the 1980s this is a common
experience now you're obviously right
you're asking me what's happening in the
UK and I'm telling you that but what I
am saying to you is there isn't one
single thing I can do sat in Whitehall
that's going to resolve this okay one
month okay fair enough but I did make
the point that actually the problem for
us is that ours is stuck others are
going down Let's do let's interrogate
some of those things just let's start
with Bank of England by the way where
you do you don't have control over what
the bank of England does but you do have
control over who is running the bank of
England and your transport secretary
colleague Grant sheps
um told my colleague Sophie Ridge
Mark Harper at beg your pardon told my
um my colleague Sophie Ridge earlier on
this week that uh
he thought that the bank would have been
too slow
well we remain in the treasury
completely aligned to the bank they as
you say have responsibility for interest
rate policy they've had that for over 25
years and if you look at it over those
25 years they've been uh pretty
effective in keeping it to the two
percent inflation Target these are
incredibly difficult times and they have
made their decision that the MPC
committee made that decision last week
and we worked closely with them in in
lockstep with them they are independent
of us so they make those judgments and
you wouldn't expect me to comment on
that yeah they're independent view but
you appoint the head so from what you
said Andrew Bailey's safe in his job for
time being well he had an eight-year
term I think he was appointed at the end
of 2019. I work very closely with Andrew
in a previous job when he was head of
the FCA and we we support him in taking
the decisions necessary so no p45
insight for Mr Bailey um can we just
deal with one other thing whether
they're loading Noises Off can we stop
talking about tax cuts now that's not
going to happen is it well you know that
we never talk about uh measures before
fiscal events
um obviously the Headroom that we had at
previous fiscal event in the spring is
now in in a different state in because
of the interest rate payments we have to
pay but basically we shut down the
economy we spent a lot of money when we
came out of covid we had a lot of debt
interest to pay that has gone up because
interest rates have gone up and that
makes our public finances very
challenging to significant once in a
hundred years and once in several
generation events a war in Europe the
government is here to deal with whatever
circumstances
are happening and we are taking the
right decisions at a difficult time as
the IMF indeed endorsed in that recent
assessment of the UK economy I'm taking
that as an answer that
um tax cuts are not on your agenda I've
got I think the prime minister's made
very clear the chances made very clear
that our priority is halving inflation
that's the dominant threat to the UK
economy and that's what we're most
focused on at this time all right let's
deal with something that is absolutely
in your control
um
one thing that wouldn't help inflation
is a big increase in energy builds and
Telegraph is reporting that uh the 170
pound a year green level levees that
were template temporarily removed are
going to come back onto bills next month
is that true were we making assessments
all the time of how we can deal with the
challenges of Supply across the economy
and the different input costs I can't
confirm uh those uh that uh this morning
but we are looking carefully at
everything that the chance they'll be
meeting with Regulators next week and we
met with the FCA and Bank lenders for
example on Friday to deal with the
pressures that households are facing
with their mortgages and we will
continue to do everything we can across
all Departments of government so I'm
taking it no decisions being taken but
the re restoration
of that Levy is on the table well in in
the sense that when governments are
facing really challenging times all
decisions are are looked at in terms of
what we can do to make the situation
better whilst continuing to recognize
that halving inflation has to remain our
priority that's the lens that the
government is consistently and unitedly
focusing on okay one way in which you
could make life easy for yourself is
um if
you passed if banks were to pass on
um the rate Rises
um to Savers in the way that the
mortgage uh increases uh are passed on
to mortgage holders Rachel Reeves uh has
written to the chancellor saying that um
there should be action from him and
Regulators to make sure that Savers
benefit from the change in interest
rates good idea Norm well I I recognize
the concern exists the chancellor
himself has recognized that that this is
something we're monitoring very
carefully we he's met with the FCA and
the banks on Friday the primary focus
was dealing with the implications of the
higher interest rates in that
conversation and several positive things
came out of that in terms of the
opportunity to go to interest only for
six months to have conversations with
your lender and not Prejudice your
credit rating as well as delaying
repossession from the first time you
miss a payment that was a constructive
set of conversations and will continue
to look at the the app if you like
between the interest on savings and the
headline rates all right well look let's
talk about something that's in your
personal uh purview and that is you've
mentioned already public sector pay now
if you want to keep
um public expenditure down a big chunk
of that is pay the times is reporting
that the prime minister is going to
overrule the independent pay review
bodies and block the recommendations for
the next round of pay sector Award of
around six percent six and a half
percent
um is that right no what what happens is
we have the reports of the pay review
bodies most of those have come in and
then we look at those and make an
assessment now obviously in some of the
disputes we've had in recent months uh
they're near to resolution we've
obviously very pleased that several of
the NHS unions have agreed the agenda
for for change deal five percent and
then four percent and some different
changes across working practices and we
will look at those pay review body
reports and that'll be the prime
minister and the chancellor working
together with input from me on what the
the right way of resolving yourself okay
let's just get this clear though you
guys have been saying for the best part
of a year when there were strikes wait
for pay review body we will support what
the independent pay review body said we
have to accept what the pay review
bodies say are you now telling me that
actually
it's not quite that we are going to look
at what the pay review bodies say and we
may accept it now what we're saying is
that we haven't had all the pay review
body uh no but as a matter of principles
as a matter of principle pay review
bodies are a very significant part of
resolving the the pay uh issues but
obviously we've also got to take account
of the effect on inflation uh that would
be irresponsible not to do that so so we
haven't finished that process forgive me
forgive me if I bang on about this
because last time I was sitting here I
can't remember which of your colleagues
were saying this to me
pay review buddy got to go with pay
review and that was when actually the
pay review was recommending something uh
lower than what the unions wanted and it
was all fine then in principle to
support pay review body what you're
telling me this morning is oh it's just
one factor we've got to think about
other things
is there other prereview bodies
recommendations only sacrosanct when
they benefit you guys I know what I'm
trying to tell you is that I can't give
you the conclusion of the pay review
body review process because I
I can't give you that yet because we
haven't finished that analysis but what
I'm saying to you is at the same time as
we're looking at that we're also aware
of the implications for inflation and
that is critical and the prime
minister's top priority has set out at
the start of the year and as he as he'll
be saying in interviews today okay I'm
sorry I don't mean to be rude but it's
just that the last time I spoke to one
of your colleagues they weren't waiting
for the pay Rue buddies to report they
simply said we'll accept what they do
what they what they're going to report
as you can see with some of these pay
review bodies and the implications and
the distribution between a non-con
payment and the weight where you do over
one year or two years these are factors
that are relevant it's not quite as
straightforward
okay
um your colleague Jillian Keegan over at
education yeah says that big pay Rises
for teachers would be inflationary yeah
and I'm quoting her here
are ongoing strikes
um uh to quote language from earlier an
earlier era perhaps
um uh ongoing strikes a price worth
paying to keep pay and inflation down I
don't think anyone wants to see strikes
across any of our Public Services I
understand what leads to that situation
but what the government's got to do is
take responsible decisions on public
spending in the round pay is a
significant element of that and
obviously I'm very aware of the massive
contribution that teachers nurses and
public sector workers make and we've got
to get the right outcomes that are fair
to them but also aren't inflationary and
as you put up on that initial slide at
the start of our conversation this
morning you know inflation is going to
be tough to get down it's something that
we're focused on and we are united and
determined to do so John Glenn thank you
very much
it has by any estimation been an
extraordinary last 24 hours in Russia
watch with baited breath around the
world
it seemed at one point that the Putin
regime stood on the brink with a column
of military vehicles heading to Moscow
the leader of the rebels you're gaining
progression of the mercenary group
Wagner has now done a deal to leave for
Belarus
the Rebellion began early yesterday
morning in rostavon Don when forces of
the Wagner group occupied the
headquarters for Russia's military
operations in Ukraine
they then seized control of military
facilities in varnish about 500
kilometers south of Moscow
a Mercury Mercury Convoy then Advanced
north of orange along the M4 Motorway
towards Moscow
Russian forces then erected defensive
positions and blockaded main roads and
bridges along the Route before the order
was given for The Mercenaries to stand
down
well let's get the very latest now from
our Moscow correspondent dynamagne who
is live in the Russian Capital uh good
morning Diana
um
what is the mood in Moscow and what is
the military situation as you understand
it
well I mean it's a sunny morning in
Moscow and I think people yesterday were
watching events with a degree of
Confusion And I think in Moscow
especially now they have a a day off
tomorrow so they're probably just
enjoying
um this peaceful resolution and uh I
think though there will be a lot of
people who are questioning what an earth
actually happened
um and given the shadow it sort of casts
over Putin's authority over his
credibility you know bear in mind the
fact that early yesterday morning he
went on television and made a big speech
talking about how this was treasonous a
stab in a part of the Russian people
essentially and only a few hours
backtracked later backtracked and let
pregojin slink off to Belarus where he
is either on route or already in situ
um it doesn't look very good for
Vladimir Putin I think there are a lot
of questions being asked as to why on
Earth a uh pregosian who is entirely a
man of the uh kremlin's own making all
of his projects over the last 10 years
have been for serving the kremlin's
purposes why Putin has constructed a
system of the power vertical where he
can't get
shogunasimov and Prego sitting around a
table with the commander-in-chief and
hash out the problems all in one room
together why it has to come to this kind
of a a Breaking Point is entirely
Putin's fault because he just likes to
keep these different factions sort of at
arm's length precaution doesn't really
have a direct line to Vladimir Putin
that's why he likes to shout and rave on
social media all the time so you know
this was a very strange situation but
frankly given the amount of noise that
pregozian has been making over the past
three or four months
um you you know one would have been
foolish to think that it couldn't have
got this far
um but I think the fact that there are
so many question marks over how quickly
it's resolved does beg a lot of
questions questions you know now if
precaution is given power and authority
to do what he wants in Belarus that is
actually going to be extremely
uncomfortable for the West for Ukraine
for the belarussian people you know
lukashenko is uh rumored to be fairly
ill he's been in Moscow quite a lot
recently I'm sure that the Kremlin is
looking around for a substitute for him
or for someone who can exert power in
Belarus and um if pregozian is still
somebody who does heed the words of
Vladimir Putin then um
he would be placed there we understand
from pregosian that he has been offered
governorships here in Russia before and
has refused them this would be quite a
good substitute now if that was part of
the plan then why did Putin come out and
make this speech and end up looking so
bad yesterday you know I don't have the
answers to this kind of thing but the
outcome if begotten ends up being a
powerful man for Russia in Belarus
against Ukraine against the West well
that suits Putin's purposes
um you know but but we don't know
essentially what happened we don't know
the state of the military perhaps
brigosian just recognized after he made
his announcement and after that column
came up to uh towards Moscow that he
simply didn't have the kind of backing
within the military or within the
security services that he might have
hoped for and that people weren't
turning to him so that's I mean it's
really difficult to know but I think so
yeah sorry Diana that's absolutely
fascinating so is it your estimation
that pagosian actually rather than sort
of riding off into the sunset is
actually going to be a a factor or could
actually now be a factor uh in the uh
Ukraine war
um well I mean he has been a
considerable factor in the Ukraine war
hasn't he because of his Wagner
mercenaries
um if he's positioned in Belarus if
Wagner takes more of a role in Belarus
if he's given power in Belarus which is
essentially up to Vladimir Putin rather
than Alexander lukashenko then Belarus
comes even more under the remit of Putin
um but it just depends if he's allowed
to take on that kind of power in in
Belarus or not and then if you have a
Wagner mercenary sitting in in Belarus
there are already lots of Russian
military bases there that in effect
gives more of a pincer movement around
Ukraine so I'm speculating here but
we'll have to see how much Authority
he's allowed to wield or if he's just
sort of essentially relegated there and
sits in Exile as as is the way it's
being cast in some circles now
um but if he is still Putin's man he
could be useful for him there
Diana thank you we'll keep uh keep
looking out for your uh fascinating
analysis on this as the days go by thank
you very much
well let's get the view from the
opposition and I can now speak to the
shadow leveling up secretary Lisa Manley
good morning
good morning good morning Trevor
um
used to be Shadow foreign secretary
um what would the what should the
current foreign secretary and the rest
of the government be saying and doing
about this situation in Russia and
Belarus now
largely actually
unusually perhaps for enough for a
politician I think they should be doing
pretty much what they are I think they
should be uh mindful of the fact that
there's a major impact on Russian
civilians of the events of the last 36
hours that this is an enormously
volatile situation it's very difficult
to predict what it means for Russia in
particular but what it does do is expose
the fragility of the Russian government
and it's clear that Ukraine is winning
the war we now need to make sure that
all of the NATO allies stand not just
with president zielinski and Ukraine to
send a clear message to President Putin
that we will be there and with the
Ukrainian people until that war is won
but also to show a completely united
front front against a splintering set of
Russian forces the phone call between
the UK the U.S France and Germany was
extremely welcome we need to see see
more of that cooperation and are
standing together in support of Ukraine
and against the actions of President
Putin
okay let's see if we can keep this
outbreak of of Harmony going when we
turn to domestic matters
um you asked the government to agree a
series of things with the banks to deal
with the Rising mortgage rate and by my
Reckoning actually they've done most of
them
um one chair for the chancellor
well the key is whether these measures
are mandatory or not and we understand
that they're not we estimate that
significant numbers of people won't be
able to access any support at all unless
the measures become mandatory so that
all mortgage payers not just some have
access to these measures that give them
more flexibility to extend mortgage
terms to be able to shift from one type
of mortgage to another we want clarity
about whether there'll be any fees or
tariffs attached to changing the terms
of your mortgage we want to ensure that
it won't affect people's credit rating
if they take up these offers these are
all questions that the chancellor has to
be able to answer if people are to be
confident that there is help coming now
and they'll be able to stay in their
homes but more importantly for far too
long the even before the Tories crash
the economy and sent mortgages through
the roof we've had an affordability
crisis in this country the reason that
people are feeling a lot of more pay now
than they were in the 90s is because the
average buyer in the 90s was borrowing
three or four times their annual salary
now they're borrowing around 11 times of
their annual salary there is no answer
to this crisis without building more
homes and that's why exactly what labor
will do well everybody everybody wants
to build more homes but let's just deal
for the moment if we can with what's
going to happen the next few months
whether it's mandatory or not all of
these measures are to some extent about
making a bad situation not so bad so
people don't lose their homes and so on
but what what can you do about the root
cause here which is inflation asked John
Glenn what policy he would have to make
things different this uh right now what
would labor do give me one thing that
labor would do to affect inflation right
now
well one of the measures that we're
pushing the government to take on today
is the fact that banks have passed on
interest rates Rises to mortgage payers
but they haven't passed on those same
interest rate Rises to Savers if you
make it more attractive for people to
save then it does have a significant
effect in cooling inflation so there are
good reasons why the government ought to
be intervening to ensure that Banks pass
on those interest rate Rises to Savers
as well and we're asking the government
to do that today so give me interrupting
you but how does putting more money in
the pockets of Savers reduce inflation
actually
traditionally Orthodox economics says it
would do exactly the opposite
well what would what we're proposing is
that the government ensures that those
Rises are passed on so it's more
attractive for people to put money into
savings in order to help cool the
economy it can't be right that banks are
passing on interest rate Rises to
mortgage payers and not to Savers we
think that's a sensible and
proportionate thing for the government
to be doing ultimately there are a
number of ways in which any responsible
government should be seeking to tackle
the inflation crisis but we think that
one of the ways that we can get out of
this mess is to get the economy growing
and you know forgive me but you said
that there's obviously everybody wants
to build more houses but the government
has just abolished local housing targets
which has sent house building off a
cliff projected to fall to its lowest
level in a generation and the house
builders Federation projects that that
will have a 17 billion pound cost to the
economy the only route out of this
crisis in the end is to bring some calm
instability to the markets and to start
getting the economy growing in every
part of Britain and that's what labor
proposes to do but if I'm forgive me if
I may just take you back to the policy
that you're espousing today which is to
put more money in the pocket of Savers
and actually by your own figures I was
looking at the release that you put out
today somebody'd have to have ten
thousand pounds in savings to get an
extra 50 Quid a year from what you're
proposing how how is that going to
affect inflation
because it makes it more attractive for
people to put money into their savings
account
a year economy if anybody's got ten
thousand to just to keep in the Savings
Bank I mean the effect will be marginal
wouldn't it
sure but what you're looking at when
you're looking at an inflation crisis of
this magnitude is a number of
multifaceted ways in which any
government has to tackle it that's what
the chancellor says that he's doing
we're proposing constructive ways in
which you can help to ease the burden
and ease the pain for people right now
and one of those ways is just to ensure
basic fairness in the way that the
banking industry is operating if they're
passing on interest rate Rises to
mortgage payers they should be passing
them on to Savers as well and we think
that would have perhaps a small effect
but a significant effect put together
with other measures in order to cool
inflation and try and take the heat out
of the economy all right the chief
Secretary of the Treasury wouldn't
commit to implementing the
recommendations of the independent pay
review bodies six percent six and a half
percent for teachers and other public
sectors workers would labor commit to
implement
the recommendations of the pay review
bodies
well we haven't seen them and we will
obviously take them seriously pay review
bodies are instructed by the government
to look at a range of factors they take
evidence from interested parties and
then they make recommendations
accordingly so they deserve to be taken
seriously but it's worth noting that we
are not in government we haven't been
allowed access to the accounts so we
don't know what the situation is and
ultimately it is for governments to
decide whether to accept those
recommendations or not if we were in
government right now we would be asking
the pay review of bodies to give far
more weight to the Recruitment and
Retention crisis in the recommendations
that we make we take seriously their
recommendations but we wouldn't be bound
for them ultimately we'd be seeking a
far more constructive relationship with
our trade unions and our Frontline
Workforce so that we could negotiate our
way through what is a very very
difficult situation and not just in
addressing the issues around pay for
Frontline workers but also addressing
the issues around working conditions in
the NHS for example it's one of the
major challenges and one of the major
reasons that people tell us that they're
leaving is because they just cannot see
light at the end of the tunnel they're
so overworked as well as struggling to
put food on the table
you're in the same place as government
is on on that question um let's have a
look at a couple of the specific
disputes the uh Railway workers the rmt
want 8.7 you sympathetic would that
would you you I understand you'd be
negotiating and so on but would you be
negotiating around that 8.7 figure
well of course we've been negotiating
around the requests that they've made
and what is ultimately affordable and
sustainable we won't make promises that
we can't keep but asking me to conduct a
negotiation live on air and make a
decision about that when I haven't seen
the books it would be a bit like asking
me to advise somebody how much more they
could afford to pay on their mortgage at
the moment without having seen their
bank account it's just not something
that an opposition can or should
responsibly be doing but I will
challenge you on one thing we certainly
wouldn't be taking the approach that
this government has been taking even
today we've had the education secretary
out attacking our Frontline teaching
Workforce for the actions that they're
taken without any acknowledgment that
the government has caused absolute havoc
in the education system over the last 13
years but particularly over the last few
years during covid when they chopped and
changed their rules and regulations at
the whim of their back benches and its
children and young people who've paid
the price
forgive me for interrupting you but I
can't let you go without asking you
about this question um
politics um uh political correspondence
is reporting that several female labor
MPS have expressed concern that all the
labor candidate for the upcoming
by-elections are white males
did that bother you
yeah of course I mean it's something
that we take very seriously in the labor
party I myself was selected on an
all-women shortlist people say now I
would have been selected anyway but the
truth is that until and unless we change
the perception of what a member of
parliament looks like
um that wasn't going to change we've
reached the threshold with the um being
allowed to use all women shortlists
again but for me and others across the
labor party it's incumbent on us to go
out and make the case for why we need
more women and more diversity in
Parliament and particularly at local
level if we're going to affect the
biggest transfer of power out of
Westminster and Whitehall in modern
British history which we are we need to
make sure that our Mayors and our
Council leaders and our cabinet members
are representative of the communities
which they serve and we're absolutely
committed to doing that listen Andy
thank you so much for your time this
morning
thank you
okay let's focus again on Russia and try
to work out what the events of the last
24 hours might mean for the conflict in
Ukraine
joining me now is the former Chief of
general staff General Lord Richard
Danner good morning General Richard
um good morning good to join you thank
you very much for joining us um what do
you make first of all of the Wagner
groups withdrawal and the way that might
affect the military balance uh in
Ukraine
well I think the first thing to say is
that um after yesterday's Fiasco I think
there are no winners
um Putin is definitely much diminished
um the Russian military and this is of
significance as far as Ukraine is
concerned is clearly in some disarray
and pregosian well apparently he's left
the stage to go to Belarus but is that
the end of pregosian and the Wagner
group the fact that he's gone to Belarus
is I think a matter of of some concern
now what we don't know but we will
discover in the next hours and days is
to well as whether how many of his
Fighters have actually gone with him
because if he has gone to Belarus and
has kept an effective fighting force
around him then he then presents a
threat again to the Ukrainian flank uh
closest to Kiev which is where all this
began on the 24th of February last year
so uh although it would appear that this
matter is closed I think it's far from
closed and the uh after if shocks of
yesterday
will reverberate for quite some time
if you were um in command in key what
would you be worried about now the uh
the progress of your counter-offensive
to the east or would you be worried
about as you've just been saying a
Potential Threat from the North in
Belarus
I would certainly want to make sure that
I've got good observation to the north
on the axis down from Belarus towards
Kiev the Russians have exploited that in
the past quite disastrously but it's
quite possible that they might do it so
again uh led by pragosian and whatever
troops he's got now as I said just now
we don't know what troops he has got at
his disposal but um we need they'll they
need to watch that um Frank very
carefully and make sure that they have
got some maneuver units such that they
could repel A Renewed attack from the
direction of Belarus meanwhile I think
that there is every reason to continue
for the ukrainians to continue their
probing attacks along the Russian
defensive line trying to find those weak
spots or weaker spots into which they
could deploy their 10 to 12 attack
brigades of highly trained Western
equipped soldiers to Endeavor to create
something of a break-in and a
breakthrough and this if they've if they
think they've found a spot or one or two
locations to do that then to consider
making that attack sooner rather than
later while the Russians themselves are
in some disarray so this is a moment of
opportunity for the ukrainians but as
we've seen over the last two or three
weeks they're being sensibly cautious
and will not commit their most valuable
Reserve troops their attack brigades
until they are sure that they found a
weak spot and could make a decisive a
decisive attack and that's the right the
right thing for them to try and do
without
um deeper intelligence I guess nobody
can say for certain but you you've been
in this these situations many many times
and I wonder what you estimate the
impact of this has been or will be on
the Russian forces because
um it's been you know widely accepted
that the wagon group were I think the
word that people have been used battle
hardened they've been the most if
amongst the most effective uh forces
that the Russians have at their disposal
uh it's not entirely clear as you say
what they're going to be doing now but
from your estimation
does this weaken Putin's military
capability or potentially uh does it
strengthen it
'd be a short answer to that question is
that it weakens it I think what we have
seen demonstrated over the last 48 hours
is disarray in the upper echelons of the
Russian command and control system it
may well be that the casualty out of all
this is defense minister Sergo
and it may well be the chief of the
general staff uh very gerasimov who is
the operational commander in Ukraine it
may be that his position uh is is
weakened
um I think the other factor to bear in
mind is that although that the Russians
have had quite some time over this
winter and spring to prepare their
defensive lines they are manned in the
main with soldiers who are poorly
trained poorly equipped and poorly led
many of whom don't want to be there many
of whom were not in the military a year
or so ago so I think the ukrainians I'm
sure have got uppermost in their mind is
that the morale of their opponents the
average Russian soldier is pretty low
and that's why if they can find some
points of weakness along the Russian
defensive lines and exploit those with
one or two decisive blows it could have
a disproportionate effect in shattering
the morale and the backbone of the
Russian army and produce some quite
significant success now I don't know if
that's going to happen I would like to
think that it might but but all these
factors together Ukraine remains in a
strong position against an enemy
albeit in prepared defensive positions
with low morale and a disjointed
Commander control structure at the
present moment whose political leader
undoubtedly has been wounded by events
in the past yes there is the pregosian
card and as I said a few minutes ago I
think we've got to watch very carefully
to see what goes in and his Wagner
troops do and there is a possible threat
that they might pose from Belarus to
Keith but if I was the Ukrainian
commander-in-chief I would watch that
front very carefully
thank you so much for your uh for your
time and also for your wisdom this
morning
thank you very much
right let's go to the domestic front now
and the political situation in Scotland
yesterday the first Minister Hamza Yusuf
had to stop a speech following a very
loud intervention from a Heckler at a
special conference meant to set out how
the s p would plot a path to
Independence well heckling is probably
the least of his worries with the party
still mired in chaos following Financial
scandals and arrests including that of
his predecessor Nicholas sturgeon oh and
the polls are looking pretty Grim for
the party that has dominated Scottish
politics for so long well I'm joined now
by the first Minister Hamza Yusuf
good morning Mr Yusuf
joining us and just as per your
introduction it's probably worth me
seeing that in virtually every single
poll that has come out of course we
still continue to be the party at least
every single other party in Scotland but
I just thought I'd just uh throw that in
there given your a very kind
introduction uh of me well kind of you
to fill us in on that but let's we'll
come back to that in a second
um you said yesterday that you would
make the next general election a
referendum on Independence does that
mean that as your predecessor it's not
what I said that if you've got 50 of the
vote you would consider that a mandate
for Independence but would it also mean
that if you didn't get 50 you just drop
it
first of all it's not what I said so
I'll clarify in a second it's worth
reminding people that of course are
preferred option the option for which we
have multiple mandates for the option in
which the majority of the Scottish
Parliament backs is of course without
legally binding referendum and that has
been denied Time and Time Again by the
UK government so my message is pretty
simple we will use the next general
election to test the proposition we'll
put a very simple proposition to the
people of Scotland on page one line one
of our Manifesto a vote for the SNP is a
vote for Scotland to become an
independent country and if we win that
general election we'll then seek to
negotiate with the UK government how we
give Democratic effect to that
proposition and we're only going down
this route of course because I continue
to reiterate because the UK government
Westminster parties continue to deny us
the right to a reference forgive me it's
an interruption when you say if we win
that general election what does that
constitute does that mean most teach in
Scotland does that mean fifty percent of
the vote what does winning the general
election sure I'm happy I'm I'm happy to
clarify but I suspect you have covered
more general elections than I have even
been involved in campaigning and every
single general election everybody knows
the rules of a general election the
party that wins the most seats wins the
general election so again if you want to
test that proposition for popular
support which is a fair enough ask to do
in fact it's what we want to do if you
want to test a proposition for popular
support you do that via referendum
that's no different to any Democratic
country in the world that wants to test
a proposition for popular support but
the rules of a general election are thus
they're of course the the party that
wins the most seats wins that general
election
okay so if you win if you win more seats
than anybody else you are going to take
that as a mandate to push for a further
uh referendum now both Rishi sumac and
Kia stalmer have said it doesn't really
matter what comes out you're not getting
one what are you going to do to force
their hands
and by the way well first and foremost
legal for them to say that
but first and foremost I would put it to
Kirsty sunak very simply you continue to
tell Scotland that this is a voluntary
Union
then prove it if you're saying that you
can't have your Independence via
referendum I'm afraid we're more accept
any uh Mandy that's given to you via a
general election this is a voluntary
Union how on Earth does Scotland become
independent but the question you ask is
a very fair one and the second part of
my speech in fact one of the main uh
main arguments I was making to our
activists and reminding our activist
base of is that it's so important for us
to ensure that we have a consistent
majority supporting Independence so
while of course we'll be campaigning in
that generation what we're doing right
now is campaigning to make sure that we
have that settled well that consistent
majority in Scotland that support
Independence because it is the power of
the people that I don't doubt will break
westminster's in transitions oh
and just
something here I mean we're talking
about democracy
if um
there's a general election and either Mr
sunac or secure starma are in Downing
Street they will have gone to the
country with a Manifesto that says we're
not going to have another referendum
they will have one in what way is it not
Democratic for them to fulfill their
mandate given to them by a ref a general
election of the United Kingdom
Scotland's not independent yet well
there's two two
well there's two points to make on that
of course if we beat labor in Scotland
then of course we win the general
election here in Scotland if you are
saying that Scotland can continue to be
denied a referendum because they are out
voted by the fact that the rest of the
UK have more seats than I would say to
you very gently that that is the
Democratic deficit which we are
continuing to rail against I'm afraid
because there is a deficit in that
regard so you are you are essentially
saying unless the rest of the UK allows
you to become independent allows you to
have a referendum and that's the only
way you can become independent that to
me doesn't sound like a voluntary Union
at all
okay all right well we could go on about
that but let's let's go on to
um the circumstances uh in which you
govern
um perhaps the best way of persuading
everybody that Scotland should be
independent would be to have
um a brilliant performance by the SNP
government in Scotland so let's address
a couple of issues which don't depend on
westminster's say so for agreement for
example the NHS you were responsible for
it in Scotland between May 21st uh May
21 and March 1923. now the number of
patients on waiting list in Scotland
is up to 780 000. there are over 18 000
people died waiting for treatment a rise
of 39 compared with 2019.
um it's not a stellar record is it
you're suggestion that somehow that is
unique to Scotland which France I'm not
suggesting it's Unique I'm just saying
it's very good for Scotland well it's
the it's the proposition it's the
proposition uh that is the premise that
underlines your question that would be
absurd of course because a global
pandemic by its definition has affected
Health Services right across the world
the pandemic was the biggest shock that
hit our NHS and it's almost
75-year existence in terms of the NHS
here in Scotland we stand in a record
that shows that Scotland's a e
departments are the best performing for
well over seven years in fact in the
winter that's just passed there was only
one nation in the UK that didn't lose a
single day to strikes in the NHS that
was Scotland of course while I was a
health secretary and when it comes to
those longest weights on the NHS if you
look at those people who've been waiting
for over two years we've made dramatic
reductions when it's inpatients
outpatients or indeed for those that are
waiting for a diagnostic tests so there
are there are challenges with the NHS
and longer to pertain otherwise but
that's undoubtedly being exacerbated by
that Global pandemic but absolutely
focused on making sure that we can
recover our NHS and social care and just
on that point you say it's not connected
to anything that Westminster does but we
all know that you don't recover your NHS
without recovering your social care one
of the biggest challenges we have of
course has been brexit if you ask
anybody involved in Social care they
will tell you how much of the workforce
and social care we've lost
weight which Scotland didn't vote for
we're wandering a bit away from your
government's performance it's still not
better
if you want to talk to if you wanted to
talk about the S P's record of course
you should report out two weeks ago
showing that because of our actions an
estimated 90 000 children will be lifted
out of poverty if you want to look at
our record and Ernst young report out
just last week shows that Scotland
outpaces the rest of the UK and Europe
when it comes to foreign direct
investment you want to talk about our
record you've got the best performing at
any departments in the entire UK if you
want to talk about our record we have
more young people going to University
from deprived areas in Scotland than
ever before I can go on and on and on if
you want but ultimately it is
not and they keep trusting they would
say that you're responsible for some of
the uh let's call them shenanigans that
have taken place in the party but you
have inherited uh a situation which has
damaged the SNP can I just get clear one
thing um
are there any circumstances in which you
would remove the whip from the MSB and
former first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
I'm not going to get hypotheticals about
what might happen in a live police
investigation you should know better
than that of course that is is
inappropriate for ministers first
ministers any elected politician to of
course comment on what is a live police
investigation I'm just asking if you
could imagine I've made it I'm not
asking you what look I've made it very
very obviously if you can imagine
circumstances in which she would lose
the whip
again I'm not going to make this about
either Nicholas Sturgeon or anybody else
but whatever else is those that have
been released without charge have been
consistent they have not had the whip
removed for them or their party
membership suspended it will keep that
situation under review but as a live
police investigation and one that I'm
not keen to comment on for that very
reason
you do accept though don't you that this
has been pretty catastrophic for your
party the chief executive of the party
arrested in April
um missing 30 000 members of purchase of
a luxury motor home worth 110
000 pounds um
did you know any of that when you stood
for the leadership
no and I made that clear at the time and
look I'm not going to argue with your
central proposition I mean it's probably
been the most difficult few months of
the party's recent modern history but
I'm the leader and I've got to make sure
I do everything I can to ensure that
there's stability within the party that
we are open and transparent that's why
instructed governance and financial
oversight uh financial review as well as
the parties conducting that at the
moment but it's also why it's important
for me to Galvanize that party and
that's why we had such a great
convention here in the city of Dundee
just yesterday so despite all those
challenges it's worth me reiterating
what I did at the very opening of the
interview we are still the most popular
party in Scotland in virtually every
single poll and of course we have by far
the most members than any other
political party here in Scotland so
that's a pretty good base to build upon
I I just want to give you the
opportunity to respond to what I think
some people say you've been a very
senior member of the SNP government for
a long time best part of a decade
it is hard to understand that you would
not have any consciousness of any of
these issues until after you became
elected as the party's leader
you can understand why that seems
bizarre to an outsider
not really because nobody's really asked
that question before because people
generally tend to understand that you
can be a senior member of the government
that doesn't mean you're a senior member
necessarily of the party because I've
actually never had an office being a
position uh in the party and for all
almost 20 years I've been involved in
the party I've had a number of pretty
tricky jobs that have kept me busy in
government whether it was transport
Minister Justice secretary or indeed
Health secretary as you just alluded to
a moment ago so uh you know I'll be up
front you ask me a pretty straight
question that I know about the various
different issues that you raised before
they were made public in the media no
the answer to that very simply as well
all right one other thing which has
caused you quite a lot of trouble
um I know that the parliament has passed
the gender recognition Reform Bill but
it is an extremely unpopular Bill
according to polls in Scotland are
barely one in five people supported
labor has said it won't support it
Tories have said they weren't supported
are you going to continue pushing for
that through uh legal action in the
courts
well first of all let me create your
assertion again and this is really basic
actually that of course the labor party
did support the gender reform
recognition but that's the liberal
Democrats as did the greens uh as of the
SNP and indeed some members of the
conservative parties who had members of
every single party uh supporting the
gender record for uh recognition reform
uh Bill actually this is a pretty simple
issue of democracy whether you agree
with the substance of the grr bill or
not we have a bill that's been passed by
the majority of Parliament that is
within our our devolved competency which
has then been vetoed by a UK government
that to me is another example of a
Westminster government that's looking
and seeking to undermine Devolution time
and time again all right forgive me I'm
just interrupting you because something
has just landed which I just want to ask
you about
um it said breaking news Scotland fire
and rescue is saying that alongside
other services across the UK the
national 999 system is experiencing
technical problems and they're urging
people to phone other numbers your
reaction how worrying is that as
somebody who's been responsible for
one of those emergency services and
health and so on
that is of course concerning him we're
of course working with Scottish fire and
rescue and others to see if that
situation can be resolved as you know
the UK Works uh right across the UK on
that 999 Airwaves system so any problems
we're of course work and collaborate
with Partners right across the UK in
that regard but uh of course the the
situation as you've expressed it is one
of concern
first minister thank you very much for
your time this morning it's been good to
talk to you thank you
thank you okay A little later after half
past I'll be on the take our challenge
to discuss this morning's interviews and
try to work out what we've learned this
morning I'm going to be joined by Claire
Ellicott from the mail on Sunday they're
acting Deputy political editor and Peter
Walker who is also the acting Deputy
political editor for the guardian and
they're with me now for a quick word
um you've been watching what stood out
for you Claire well I think I'm the most
pressing issue is obviously
um Russia but I think John Glenn's
comments on on mortgages the situation
the economic situation at the moment
that's what's really um people are
really concerned about and he didn't
really say much did he we didn't really
get a lot out of him we don't really
know what the government's going to be
doing about any of this obviously Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor he's holding the
banks he's going to be hauling in The
Regulators speaking to supermarkets
about costs but really it does feel like
there's not a lot the government can
actually do to reassure people people
who really will be worrying about their
mortgages at the moment Peter were you
shocked and surprised by anything you
heard and I was
I I noticed I mean you very much picked
this up but when John Glenn was talking
about the public sector pay you were
making the point that if this Sunday
time story is right and they turned down
what the pay review board is do you say
I mean we all know that it's not a
mandatory process it's a recommendation
so the government's always been able to
say yes we will or yes we won't but
they've made a bit of a bind for
themselves with these previous strikes
they said oh no we can't possibly give
any more because this is what the public
sector body says and they've kind of
boxed themselves into a corner now
because these bodies which they've been
talking up for months and months might
now give a figure that they don't like
and they're gonna have to say actually
no it's just a recommended one so I
think that's politically quite
interesting they've created a bit of a
problem for themselves there indeed all
right we're going to talk more before we
do move on to the take let's return to
that story which is of course dominated
the weekend's news events in Russia and
the abortive coup that seemed to have
been launched and then walked back by
the now exiled mercenary leader Evgeni
pregosian and I'm going to get some
expert analysis from former British
intelligence officer Christopher Steele
and the former British Military
Intelligence officer Philip Ingram good
morning Christopher good morning uh
Philip good morning good morning uh
Christopher well what do you make of
where we've got to this morning
um it seems was it all a lot of fuss
about nothing or has something changed
no I think something has changed and
what's changed I think is that the
Vladimir Putin has lost Authority and
legitimacy within Russia and has been
challenged in a way yes he's managed to
worm his way out of it for the for the
present but to see events unfold in
Russia yesterday and the speed with
which the situation seemed to spiral out
of control must be very concerning for
Putin and the people around him
uh
and uh so what do you think
is it is the takeaway here that Putin is
weaker than he was uh on Thursday
well I think that's one of the takeaways
definitely but the other bit that's
there is there's an awful lot we don't
know yet uh your pregosian won't have
done this in isolation
um he's achieved an awful lot you know
he's he's driven hundreds of kilometers
in less than 24 hours when it took him
um 18 months to fight through seven
kilometers inside Ukraine
um you know he has embarrassed shoigu by
getting a military capability that was
under Russian mod command allegedly and
taking it out and
um taking it into Russia capturing one
of Russia's largest cities bloodlessly
and then driving towards Moscow and
threatening the whole regime there's a
lot more to play out with this
let's assess who has who has most to
worry about about let's put Putin to one
side for a moment but um it sounds like
we haven't heard anything from shoigu or
garasimov the military leaders
um
does anybody think that they have
essentially uh been taken out of the
picture Christopher
it's too early to say yet but my strong
feeling would be that uh shoigu is
finished
um when the garasimov's survives is
another matter of course Putin doesn't
want to be seen to look weak by getting
rid of them in the immediate aftermath
of this debacle and it may take a few
weeks to play out but my guess would be
that shoigu won't be defense minister
for that much longer and I'm really
asking about this because in the end the
big thing uh here Philip is what will it
mean for the war in Ukraine does this
give ukrainians a little bit of an edge
or is it something that makes no
difference or as Diana Magnum might have
been was suggesting earlier on that
actually it means that there's somebody
competent and dangerous in Belarus now
who will add strength to Putin's hand
well the answer is yes to all of those
um in reality from a tactical
perspective is it affecting the
Ukrainian counter-offensive and the
Russian defense on the ground not really
you know the Russian soldiers that on
the ground are too interested in
protecting their own lives and saving
their own lives the ukrainians are still
having to fight through minefields that
are still there tank traps that are
still there defensive lines that are
still there however where it does start
to help is when it comes to the wider
coordination uh that there is in the
support that's going into Ukraine and
the ability to plan forward because the
Russian military approach approach is a
very top-down approach orders come from
the very top and are executed at the
lowest levels there's no initiative
within that whatsoever so there's
creating confusion in there and the
ukrainians have got an opportunity here
they can add more confusion at an
operational level by destroying other
command and control headquarters
Logistics hubs lines of communication
which will cause the higher demand who
are confused by everything that's going
on and even bigger headache that gives
them a real opportunity that they can
exploit tactically on the ground but it
will take a few days or a week or so for
that to properly come through and so we
are in early days at the moment uh
Christopher let me ask you finally the
the usual unfair TV journalists uh
question
um look forward a year
will Putin still be there and looking
closer in the Horizon
um what can we do in this country or in
the west to make sure that uh that
balance tips uh in the way that the
ukrainians want
I think it's important to say first of
all that you know we shouldn't be
interfering in in Russian internal
politics to talk with a view to toppling
a regime however obviously we want the
Russians to withdraw from from Ukraine
and to become a more responsible State I
think the main thing we can do is try
and ensure Ukrainian Victory on the
battlefield because I think that is
where this whole thing will be decided
in the end
thank you both for for your commentary
um we don't know what's going to happen
but no doubt we'll be on it all the time
that's it for this week's Sophie Ridge
on Sunday in a moment after the break
we'll run through today's interviews and
see what we learn in the take thanks for
joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back this is Sophie Ridge on
Sunday the take a chance to look back at
our interviews this morning on the
program and try to work out what we've
learned and what it means for the week
ahead
well with me our clear Ellicott the mail
on Sunday's acting Deputy political
editor and Peter Walker acting Deputy
political editor for the guardian
um
now
I asked the chief Secretary of the
Treasury John Glenn whether the
instability thrown up by the Rebellion
on Russia should make the West look
again at how it supports Ukraine
so nothing has changed with respect to
the British government's position in
supporting Ukraine I obviously recognize
these are concerning events uh of what's
happened in Russia but as I said we will
remain very close to our allies Cobra
has evaluated
alongside our allies what has been
happening and urged concerns of
civilians to be taken into account but
this isn't something that we would
intervene in it's an internal matter for
Russia
uh Claire that's um a rather distinctly
hands-off approach isn't it I was I was
a bit surprised by that well I think
that the Western governments are very
keen to not give Putin any ammunition to
say that they're getting at all involved
in domestic affairs in Russia and um it
would suit the Western governments as
well to just keep well out of this
because whatever happens in Russia it
looks like Putin's been dealt a blow and
his authority has been weakened and if
you sit on the sidelines and and wait to
see what unfolds that's got to be a
better position than getting involved in
saying anything so I think they'll
continue with this
um but it you know it remains to be seen
how how much Putin has been weakened by
this we've got the Wagner boss he's now
in Belarus he's been seems like he's
exiled from Russia but it was
extraordinary yesterday watching what
happened I mean we don't know what went
on and it doesn't really make sense um
so I think there'll be far more to learn
about what's happened in this crisis but
either way it's got to be it's got to be
a sort of good thing for Ukraine and for
the West that you know Russia has Russia
does look like it's in Peril in a way it
hasn't done for a long time you agree
Peter and
um if you do
um what should we be doing study she
goes or ramp up the support I mean I
think Claire is completely right in the
sense that there's the vested interest
for the UK to not want to get involved
in the internal affairs of Russia
because that's a completely different
thing and to even give this information
of wanting Putin to go would give
ammunition for the Kremlin to kind of
say you know the UK is very much taking
aside on this but more than that there's
not actually that much we can do I mean
I get the sense that in government
yesterday they were
on a kind of higher level scale to all
of us all of us punters were watching it
on Twitter and watching it on live blogs
and just not knowing what was going to
come next and obviously their
intelligent sources are better but they
were basically doing the same thing they
were watching this Convoy Advanced down
the motorway turn around and go back and
you know people in Russia didn't know
what was going to take in place there
was probably a dozen people in the
entire world who knew what might take
place next so there was almost little
that they could do except watch and you
know I think be careful to not I hope
for too much too quickly because you
know revolutions as everyone knows can
go all sorts of very uh unexpected ways
it's weird isn't it it's a sort of an
attempted coup blink and you missed it
yeah let's um let's hear what Labor's
Shadow leveling up secretary Lisa nandy
uh had to say she hinted that in her
view the government is pretty much
getting it right so far in its response
to the Russian Russia Rebellion
usually perhaps fair enough for a
politician I think they should be doing
pretty much what they are I think they
should be uh mindful of the fact that
there's a major impact on Russian
civilians of the events of the last 36
hours that this is an enormously
volatile situation it's very difficult
to predict what it means for Russia in
particular but what it does do is expose
the fragility of the Russian government
and it's clear that Ukraine is winning
the war
uh Peter this of course is a television
political interviewer's nightmare that
the shadow okay the shadow leveling up
secretary and the cabinet secretary
completely uh agree annoying as hell but
um are there any political opportunities
here for the opposition to exploit
I generally don't think there are except
to try and look as kind of Statesman and
States woman like as they can because I
I think the UK would have taken this
very pro-ukraine role anyway but Boris
Johnson when The Invasion took place was
very keen to try and position the UK
from a PR front you know it's very much
where Pro Ukraine try and help them as
much as we can and that's proved to be a
very electorally popular thing and you
know again I think labor would have
almost certainly taken the same thing
but you know for a political interview
point of view not only do they agree
they also can't really add that much we
are watching from the sidelines as these
world events take place
There is almost nothing they can do
except you know as Lisa nandy said you
know there's not much we can do but what
the government is doing is probably the
right thing
no I totally agree I don't think labor
can do anything about this so I think
what's really really interesting about
about the Mutiny is that Putin is
obviously he's invaded around Ukraine
he's you know this is all Dreadful but
the Wagner group who goes in he's not
exactly a good man
um you know he runs a band of thugs a
lot of them are convicts who are
liberated from jails in Russia to go and
fight in Ukraine they've been accused of
all sorts of Human Rights abuses these
aren't necessarily people we want with
nuclear you know to have power over
nuclear weapons so that there's a you
know the position here is probably the
you know your enemy's enemy is you know
maybe this is a good from the standpoint
that there's there are problems in
Russia but you can't support either side
besides all right okay fair enough let's
see this is politics so let's let's see
if we can have any heated round now
let's go to domestic politics I put it
to John Glenn the chief secretary to the
treasury that tax cups look incredibly
unlikely given the efforts to bring
inflation down uh or under control at
least with Rising interest rates
now basically we shut down the economy
we spent a lot of money when we came out
of covid we had a lot of uh debt
interest to pay that has gone up because
interest rates have gone up and that
makes our public finances very
challenging to significant once in 100
years and once in several generation
events of war in Europe the government
is here to deal with whatever
circumstances
are happening and we are taking the
right decisions at a difficult time as
the IMF indeed endorsed in their recent
assessment of the UK economy
you know I am getting on but I don't
think I heard anything that sounded like
a plan or even an idea about bringing
the bringing inflation down there I
think this is the real trouble that the
sort of underlying price Rises
government can't really do much about
you have Jeremy Hunt the chancellor
trying to you know say that he's
bringing in the banks he's speaking to
Regulators he's speaking to supermarkets
about prices but in real times there's
not much the government can really do
and
you know the public is punishing the
government for this labor is doing
really really well in the polls and
Rishi sunak has you know a former
Chancellor and a man who who should know
about the economy I don't think the
public are getting the reassurance that
that they need from the government and
um I mean the fact is that this will be
you know John Glenn has the position
that you know that we can't talk about
tax Rises yet but if the Tories want to
win the next election I think they're
going to have to do something but while
inflation is this High their hands are
tied and there really isn't much they
much comfort they can offer to
homeowners or to to voters uh we're
hearing that the Prime Minister has
advised homeowners
to hold their nerve over mortgage
interest rates how do you nurse Peter my
nerves like must have that most of the
restoration is slightly fraudible
um you know of us go to my bank and say
no it's fine you know I feel very
relaxed about this I'm sure they'll be
fine so I I think that John Glenn
interview I think if I was a
conservative MP watching that I would be
simultaneously quite miserable and I
would have thought it was nothing
unexpected because the whole thing is
that conservative MPS were even a few
months ago could privately say they
could foresee this kind of Landing Zone
where even not an election win but a
hunk Parliament could take place the
closer the election gets the tinier and
tinier that zone gets and the more the
options have been closed off and it
makes sense for him to effectively rule
out tax cuts we had the Liz trust
experiment of doing tax cuts when the
public finances were not in a great
state and interest rate Rises means
they're even tougher now and so it'd be
politically very very fraught but then
the biggest problem is is that we've had
high inflation rates so people are
already feeling much much poorer indeed
and then suddenly this is going to come
and the question that everybody asked
before General uh election is
do I feel you know financially better
off that I did last time around and the
answer for most people is going to be no
well one part of the answer might be pay
which we will talk about after the break
[Music]
it's actually really important for us to
be looking at these images and to
understand what's happening so as we saw
last week
this shipwreck was something that Greek
authorities were actually new about
pre-happening
so what's really important is to
understand that these deaths were really
our fault and there's something that
could have been avoidable still
preventable exactly they were really
unavoidable and for us to be able to
recognize that we are responsible for
these deaths I think is really crucial
and until we're not able both in Greece
the rest of Europe and the UK to offer
safe legal routes for people to get here
is some
I think that I've talked about in this
book that is getting published this week
as someone who came from Greece himself
you know I have to say unfortunately
because there isn't innocent fruits
people are taking you know this uh
horrible Journeys to come to the UK or
reach to a safe country but like and
everyone is like oh why you are doing
this kind of things but because there is
an answer fruit so I guess if you know
the governments can help people to open
a safe route so they can follow that you
know that Ruth to come to the UK instead
of taking this Journeys otherwise you
know many people are going to die like
we had over eight like around 80 people
have lost their life just three days ago
or like a few few months ago even the I
think that she was drunk in Italy and
many people have died again not long ago
in France again on the way to the UK
started this book because of my
frustration with a lot of mainstream
media and politicians and the way that
they
scapegoat a lot of refugees and Asylum
Seekers and also represent them as you
know villains we know the stereotypes of
people invading our borders invading our
countries and not really looking at
people as humans and recognizing that as
you will see in the book everyone has a
different Journey like Ali has just
shared with us different stories and
being able to recognize that these are
people seeking safety is a way to then
be able to I hope to have empathy and
care for people once they do get here
and this variety of of stories is is
shown in these posters and these
conversations and really makes us look
at the issue in a much more wholehearted
way I hope
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Sophie Ridge on Sunday
the take where we take you through some
of the analysis of the morning's
interviews uh I asked the chief
Secretary of the Treasury John Glenn if
the Prime Minister was planning to
overrule the independent pay review
bodies for the next round of public
sector pay Awards
no what happens is we have the reports
of the pay-review bodies most of those
have come in and then we look at those
and make an assessment now obviously in
some of the disputes we've had in recent
months they're near to resolution we've
obviously very pleased that several of
the NHS unions have agreed the agenda
for change deal five percent and then
four percent and some different changes
across working practices and we will
look at those pay review body reports
and that will be the Prime Minister and
the chancellor working together with
input from me on what the the right way
of resolving yourself
with me are Claire Ellicott the mail on
Sundays acting Deputy political editor
and Peter Walker acting Deputy political
editor for the guardian um
Claire
they they are backing off the support
for the independent pay review because
they kept saying before
leave it you know we're going to support
the play review bodies suddenly not so
sure no it does feel like that so John
Glenn is clearly not making any promises
we've got pay right the pay review
bodies expected to
um say that you know a lot of these a
lot of public sector workers are going
to be in line for six percent pay Rises
and looks like the government are going
to argue this would be inflationary
inflation's a big problem we need to get
it down and so therefore we can't accept
these recommendations they'll almost
certainly argue that they came out
before we found out that inflation's
stickier than the government and a lot
of experts have thought and is not
moving
um but it will be very little comfort of
two public sector workers who think they
do need a pay rise and we've been you
know over the past year we've just seen
strike after strike after strike they
will be emboldened to do this more and
you know the government isn't a bit of a
buying because they have said that you
know we are going to follow these
recommendations that you know that was
their way of kind of trying to take the
political heat out of this row but now
if they oppose that it does look very um
it looks very shaky of them to do that
well hold that thought for a moment
let's see if we got anything different
from Lisa nandy for the opposition
if we were in government right now we
would be asking the pay review bodies to
give far more weight to the Recruitment
and Retention crisis in the
recommendations that we make we take
seriously their recommendations but we
wouldn't be bound for them ultimately
we'd be seeking a far more constructive
relationship with our trade unions and
our Frontline Workforce so that we could
negotiate our way through what is a very
very difficult situation and not just in
addressing the issues around pay for
Frontline workers but also addressing
the issues around working conditions in
the NHS for example one of the major
challenges and one of the major reasons
that people tell us that they're leaving
is because they just cannot see light at
the end of the tunnel they're so
overworked as well as struggling to put
food on the table
um Peter the the tone is a little bit
different you know we'll work with the
Union until uh
but basically she's also saying that
we're not going to commit to supporting
the pay review recommendations
she was but the fact that she's making
reference to Recruitment and Retention
of staff I think is a big
kind of key element to it which is
making the point that you know you can
try and push down pay as much as you
want and I mean for the government it's
almost the definition of a government
that is in is in trouble or is in kind
of difficulties that whatever option
they pick there's no easy way around
because they've tied themselves to this
Mast of having inflation by the end of
the year so they have to devote
everything towards that but voters don't
only judge a government by whether they
meet this kind of Target they've given
they also judged them a lot on whether
things work and if things are going on
people are going on strike all the time
and services are getting worse and worse
then they judge them by that too and if
you're a public sector worker when
inflation is currently well above six
percent saying not only can you not have
six percent you have to have less than
that then you would imagine the chances
are more teachers or doctors whatever
will leave and go to other jobs or will
hold
um strike action and it gets into this
situation where people think the country
just isn't working very well and with
with listen Andy I think it's
interesting she was seemed to me it felt
like she was hinting that she would want
to give them what they would you know
whether you've been interviewing Rachel
Reeves if she'd given a slightly
different answer you know only only will
tell and it's a tricky one for labor
because they have this
very very kind of strong imperative not
to be seen as
fiscally likely to spend too much money
but they have to keep the unions on site
too Claire 10 seconds do you think um Mr
sumac's actually inspiring any
confidence yet
I think it's a real problem for them I
think the Tories want to you know the
economy to get better in the run-up to
the next election they're hoping that
inflation reduces
um so that they have something to offer
voters but it is looking very very shaky
okay well later today the Sophie Ridge
on Sunday podcast will have the best of
our interviews discussed by myself the
political Communications advisor Laura
Emily Dunn and our program editor Scott
Beasley you can listen to that a little
later on today on the Sky News app or if
you scan the QR code on your screen now
you can subscribe for free wherever you
get your podcast thank you Claire and
thank you Peter that's it from safety
Ridge on Sunday the take this morning by
the way nine o'clock tonight watch our
Windrush documentary bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]